pékin 27 mai 1976 mouse et toulouse
reçoit le premier ministre pakistanais
monsieur ali bhutto
c'est la dernière image de main aux
vivants deux semaines après le 15 juin
le comité central du parti communiste
chinois annonçait que mao affaibli par
la maladie ne pourrait plus recevoir de
visiteurs étrangers de passage en chine
et puis aujourd'hui la nouvelle est
tombée
mao est mort aussitôt à pékin tous les
drapeaux officiels ont été mises en
berne alors que d'autres apparaissait
aux fenêtres des habitations
par ailleurs aucune mesure
exceptionnelle de sécurité ne semble
avoir été prise voilà pour le côté
officiel mais plus intéressantes sont
les réactions de la population qui
visiblement a été choqué par le décès de
mao
beaucoup de chinois porte déjà le
brassard noir d'autres arborent épinglé
sur leurs vêtements
un chrysanthème blanc couleur du deuil
en chine et puis surtout dans divers
endroits de la capitale des groupes se
rassemblent au pied des portrait géant
de mao le visage en larmes ou
profondément marqués par le chagrin ce
chagrin populaire bien réel prouve à
quel point ma route et tous étaient
identifiés à son peuple et à quel point
il en était véritablement devenu le
guide suprême
le correspondant de l'agencé france
presse à pékin on a été lui même le
tempo en compagnie d'harry interprète in
war la non à la radio
en asie pas ma sympathie aux autres
membres du bureau pour les camions et
frappe également dans tout et quand on
l'a vu à l'epad
immédiatement après l'annoncé de la
nouvelle
beaucoup pleuraient
ce sont des vins des hommes des femmes
le temps passé devant le portrait en
couleur de base ou la mort du président
mao c'est tout aussitôt qu'elle a été
connue a bien sûr provoqué des réactions
officielles à peu près dans tous les
pays du monde nous y reviendrons tout à
l'heure les manifestations de deuil et
de sympathie ont également eu lieu dans
différentes capitales comme à paris où
une ce soir puis 19 heures devant
l'ambassade de chine le quotidien
l'humanité rouge de tendance au pro
chinoise organise un rassemblement à la
mémoire du président défunt
ce matin l'annoncé du décès du président
chinois a bien sûr bouleversé
l'actualité dès que nous avons eu
connaissance de l'information nous avons
interrogés au hasard dans les rues de
paris
quelques passants leur réponds vous
allez le voir montre à quel point la
signification du rôle joué par mao était
bien perçu il est ma nouvelle de savoir
quel genre de réflexions vous inspirent
ces événements
je crois que pour la chine c'est
important parce que je ne sais pas s'il
y a quelqu'un pour le remplacer
je pense que déjà les hommes qui doivent
le remplacer sont en place il est mort
soissons chine
non mon rapport pour ça mourir j'estime
que il doit avoir fait des grandes
louches à lui vu que vu que son pays ait
été en retard de plusieurs de plusieurs
dizaines d'années de type que parti
vraiment c'était quand nourrir ou 800
millions de bouches c'était c'était
quelque chose mais il faut savoir celui
qui va à peu près maintenant il est
certain qu'il avait la stature d'un
homme politique mondiale pas de bonne
politique de par l'importance de la
chine c'est certainement à l'événement
c'est un des derniers grands qui
disparaissent disparaît
comme le prouvent ces témoignages
choisis au hasard mao était vraiment
pour tout le monde et pour tout le monde
vraiment adversaires ou partisans un
personnage hors du commun une
personnalité qui ne peut laisser
personne indifférent
et c'est pourquoi ce soir après ce
journal la rédaction d'antenne 2 vous
présentera une soirée spéciale consacrée
à la mort du président chinois
cette soirée sera composé d'abord d'un
film intitulé ma roue par lui-même qui
contient des textes entièrement inédit
de mao ainsi que des images originales
tirées du premier film jamais tourné sur
mao tsé toung
la diffusion de ce film sera suivi d'un
débat auquel participeront plusieurs
personnalités spécialiste de la chine
comme le général guillermo le
réalisateur joris ivens le président de
l'assemblée nationale monsieur edgar
faure monsieur etienne manach
contiennent en ce bas salaires de france
à pékin
rené viennet l'auteur du film que vous
aurez vu en première partie vous
entendrez donc les témoignages de ces
différentes personnalités mais vous
pourrez également selon la formule des
dossiers de l'écran participer vous même
au débat en appelant svp salies en
revenir à l'actualité
la disparition d'un homme qui était
entré de son vivant dans la légende
comme il est convenu de lire un même
bien évidemment à se demander que
va-t-il se passer en chine après mao
dans l'immédiat du point de vue des
structures il faut tout de suite dire
qu'après la mort du grand timonier comme
l'appelaient les chinois le pays ne se
retrouve pas 100 personnes au gouvernail
un premier ministre est en place et
depuis quelques temps déjà les
dirigeants chinois s'était préoccupé de
prévoir l'après mao un détail par
exemple ou aujourd'hui dès l'annoncé du
décès de nombreux habitants de pékin
portait déjà le brassard noir ou le
chrysanthème blanc un signe du deuil en
chine et a dit la fatalité est tout de
même venue compliquer les choses car la
disparition du président intervient au
milieu d'une année particulièrement
difficile pour la chine en février le
premier ministre monsieur tout et night
day c day et au mois de juillet un
tremblement de terre faisait plusieurs
centaines de milliers de victimes
ce sont les dernières images reçues en
occident provenance de pékin
elle date du 1er septembre dernier
prennent aujourd'hui une signification
toute particulière ici donc le bureau
politique s'est réuni au grand complet à
pékin pour célébrer la mémoire des héros
du tremblement de terre de tangshan et
c'est en effet la première fois depuis
la mort de schwann lie que les
dirigeants chinois se présente de façon
unie en oubliant les querelles qui les
divise
un peu comme si déjà le 1er septembre
dernier la mort de mao zedong et est une
réalité
et puis sans aucun doute la terrible
catastrophe tremblement de terre aura
servi à mettre la population chinoise en
condition les dirigeants pékin ont
multiplié les appels au calme et à
l'unité
il y a quelques jours encore le premier
ministre chinois a assuré que le peuple
armé le pc pouvaient soutenir les
épreuves les plus rigoureuses et
surmonter n'importe quelle difficulté
là encore comme si déjà le président
mode ses tongs et paiement cette
politisation poussé à l'extrême d'un
phénomène naturel a donc eu comme
résultat de préparer 800 millions
d'hommes à l'épreuve suprême la
disparition de leur chef année cruciale
année terrible pour la chine la mort de
mao zedong ce matin le tremblement de
terre il ya quelques mois la mort de
schwann light
ainsi dieu est mort pour un être humain
sur trois disparaît ce visage rond sur
lequel le monde entier guettait depuis
quelques temps avec angoisse ou avec
délectation les rides les traces de
l'usure au tsé toung a vécu ce que peu
d'hommes ont vécu quelque chose comme la
vie d'un christ son golgotha tard il
était la dernière des statuts l'histoire
de gaulle churchill staline des
silhouettes à qui personne en fait ne
peut succéder
sa puissance son pouvoir était si grand
qu'il se permettait à intervalles
réguliers de remettre en cause les
structures qu'il avait lui-même imposé
sa pensée à pénétrer dans la vie
quotidienne de tous les peuples du monde
certains il trouve la paix d'autres le
sang cette aventure fantastique d'un
homme qui pour beaucoup est le visage du
mal dont l'oeuvre cette chine
d'aujourd'hui est loin d'être un modèle
pour le reste du monde
cette aventure fantastique va être la
dramatique le véritable théâtre de cette
soirée
l'existence de mao tsé toung est une
histoire qu un film exceptionnel vous
allez voir pas ressuscité c'est aussi
l'histoire les cadrans tâche qui aligne
pour nous intriguer les questions dont
la réponse sera la tranquillité où
l'inquiétude des mois ou des années qui
viennent premièrement qui va prendre le
pouvoir à pékin la gauche extremis des
villes des universités de la presse ou
les modérés des campagnes de caen qui
s'équilibre aujourd'hui deuxièmement le
centre qui avait qu à opio feng gouverne
en ce moment va-t-il pouvoir résister et
réclamer son héritage troisièmement que
va faire l'immense armée chinoise
quatrièmement ce visage apparemment
lisse silencieux et cannes de la chine
va tu vu de l'occident va-t-il se
craqueler sous la poste la poussée des
ambitions et des querelles et si oui
quand cinquièmement tout ce que nous
avons pu comprendre et interpréter la
chine va t-il se révélait exact où nous
sommes nous complètement trompé en somme
la question que l'on se pose dans le
monde ce soir est de savoir si l'
influence la pensée de mao tsé toung
était suffisamment forte comme on le
disait pour obliger les chinois à le
suivre
même après sa mort avec le président mao
tsé toung
c'est un un phare de la pensée mondiale
venue de la profondeur populaire de la
chine
l'ayant arraché à son humiliation passé
il a réussi par la seule vigueur de son
action et par l'audace de sa réflexion
à lui rendre la place centrale que lui
reconnaissaient l'histoire par la voix
de son président le peuple français
adresse à l'immense peuple chinois
l'expression de ses profondes
condoléances pour la perte de celui
qu'il appelait son grand timonier à
bruxelles il y a deux organisations
internationales qui devraient prendre le
deuil c'est l'otan et le marché commun
l'otan l'organisation militaire du
traité de l'atlantique nord vient de
perdre un allié objectif la chine de mao
n'a cessé de prodiguer des sourires à
l'otan parce que c'est une institution
militaire dirigée contre l'urss le
marché commun a reçu aussi une foule
d'encouragement de la chine de mao
parce que c'est une institution destinée
à faire pièce à l'influencé soviétique
en europe occidentale commercialement
les relations entre la chine et les
communautés européennes ne vont pas très
loin mais politiquement ils sont presque
chaleureuse
d'ailleurs depuis le mois de septembre
dernier la chine de mao est représentée
par un ambassadeur auprès des
communautés européennes annoncées par
gerald ford rend hommage au grand
timonier nixon se tait kissinger 5 t ros
et déjà les sinologues américains qui
n'ont pas tardé à plancher sur la
déclaration de l'agencé chine nouvelle
ont souligné en rouge
une petite phrase nous sommes décidés à
libérer taïwan cette volonté de
reprendre ce que
pékin considère toujours comme une
province chinoise embarrassé inquiète
washington
elle confirme les appréhensions du
leader républicain yoox code qui est
allé récemment en chine communiste et
qui a insisté sur la nervosité des
nouveaux dirigeants chinois
le temps n'est plus où dessus en laye
pouvait encore dire nous sommes un
peuple patient pékin pourrait donc
mettre l'amérique au pied du mur et lui
demander de choisir définitivement entre
les héritiers de mao et ceux de tchang
kaï-chek un choix difficile les
businessmen américains rappellent
souvent qu'une vraie lune de miel
économiques et commerciales vaut mieux
qu'un flirt platonique
les réactions officielles sont une chose
ou non de les écouter les témoignages
humains en sont une autre
celui je vous propose d'entendre
maintenant et celui de joris ivan
cinéaste qui a pendant très longtemps
vécu en chine et qui a été pratiquement
le seul à tourner où il voulait sur le
territoire chinois
son film you kong des plats salés
montagne est d'ailleurs sorti cette
année en france qui était l'homme qui se
cachait derrière la légende derrière le
mythe
c'est la question à laquelle essaie de
répondre jory steve monde c'est tout
c'est pourquoi ma revue dix mille fois
vingt mille fois savait pas dire
personnellement serrer la main mais mes
contacts avec lui était toujours à
travers les chinois parce que je l' ai
vu quelques fois la tribune va mettre
deux mois et quelquefois tout près aussi
mais quelques feintes eu près aussi dans
une réception que ce qu'elle
impressionne et il lorsqu'on était à
quelques mètres simplement de lui ça a
été à ce moment quand j'ai vu c'est
avant qu'il a été déjà faibles par une
maladie c'était un homme très sûr de lui
qui porte en soi un peu la dignité de
tout le peuple chinois he c'était une
présence incroyable qui n'est pas sûr
imposée parce que tu penses c'est un
grand nom
on s'est vraiment en contact direct avec
ce temps que j'ai vu aussi des autres
gens comment être supporter puisque vous
avez approché très souvent comment tu
portes est il ce culte de la
personnalité qui l'entouraient est ce
qu'il le voulait ce culte
non pas du tout si vous voulez les
jeunes
l'interview qui l'a vu avec écrivains
américains edgar chenaux et pas très
fort contre ça un certain moment à la
fin de la révolution culturelle a eu
certaines tendances vers cette cause des
personnalités mais lui absolument pas
pas eu plus de chine ne porte le nom de
notre temps ça n'existe pas comme m
comment expliquez vous jouerez 6,27
domination au sens propre du terme qui
exerçait moitié tout sur le peuple
chinois
j'allais dire sur ces sujets car tout à
la fois il arrivait à les sécuriser
d'une part mais aussi à les sublimer
oui je pige pas tout à fait d'accord
avec domination j'ai pas les choses que
j'ai vues et c'est pour ça que je suis
dit j'ai dit mille fois dix mille fois
rencontrer c'est quand même aussi un
respect un amour c'est très rare dans
l'histoire d'une tout un peuple et un
peuple de vie 100 millions qui dès leur
recommencement où ils ont encore ces néo
colonisés très supérieur à travers toute
lutte
il a été toujours là et à la point
névralgique celui qui a donné aussi la
direction sa relation avec son peuple
qui est pour moi presque unique tamoul
mais c'est lui qui a dit et tout le
peuple était d'accord avec cris en 49 la
tribu où j'ai vu maintenant en 49
maintenant le peuple chinois est débout
et pour toujours
l'apologie d'un homme surtout quand il
est mort est souvent de règles
personnalité hors du commun on le sait
tous il était sans nul doute mais
personnalités également inquiétante même
pour ceux qui ne cachent pas leur
fascination
c'est le cas d'andré malraux par exemple
qui dansaient antimémoires écrit il y à
un pays voué à la vengeance et la
justice un pays qui ne déposera pas les
armes qui ne déposera pas l'esprit avant
l'affrontement planétaire déjà 300 ans
d'ère européenne s'efface l'air chinoise
commence après intel table on serait
tenté de dire par réaction que
l'histoire a prouvé qu'aucun chef d'état
n'était irremplaçable mais tout de même
lorsqu'on essaie de retracer la vie de
nos c'est tout on reste fasciné par la
volonté la puissance qu'a déployé cet
homme pour faire de la chine
une véritable nation de 800 millions
d'habitants
au commencement était la chine le jeune
mao tsé toung étudiants aide
bibliothécaire à l'université de pékin
mao tsé toung élevé dans l'ancienne
tradition des lettrés et qui accorde
presque autant d'importance à ces poèmes
qu'à ses écrits politiques et nourrit de
la tradition chinoise
il est né ici un shaoshan en 1893 dans
cette chine du sud dont il gardera
toujours l'accent est le langage
aujourd'hui un lieu de pèlerinage où des
milliers de visiteurs viennent chaque
jour
à
ici mao tsé toung aurait pu être
seulement un paysan aisé mais le goût du
nouveau et l'appétit du savoir vont
l'entraîner au loin un statut qu'admire
les visiteurs le montre revêtu de la
longue robe de ce qu'ils étudiaient
celle qu'ils portaient quand il est
parti pour l'école normale de changsha
le père un paysan enrichi ne comprend
pas son fils qui préfèrent la lecture au
commerce du riz la première révolte de
mao et familiale la seconde est à la
fois nationale et sociale une révolte au
nom de cette chine
déchu de son antique splendeur qui peine
et qui piétine au seuil du 20e siècle
à
en 1912 souvenir de celle a proclamé la
première république chinoise
mais la république a été confisqué par
les seigneurs de la guerre c'est au
bureau militaire à la fois caricaturaux
et redoutable qui se partagent le pays
et le d'épaisses le premier unificateur
de cette chine anarchique s'appelle
chang kai shek partie du sud
c'est trop de monde vers le nord en
refoulant les seigneurs de la guerre
elle entre à shanghai le souffle un vent
de folie et la à shanghai en 1927
shanghai cheikh bron brutalement
l'alliance qu'il avait noués avec le
jeune parti communiste chinois
il fait massacrer les militants
communistes
c'est le début d'une guerre civile qui
va durer vingt ans mao tsé toung l'un
des fondateurs du parti communiste a
échappé au massacre
il se retourne vers le sud ses rizières
ces paysans aux confins de sa province
natale du hunan et du cabc il se réfugie
avec une poignée d'hommes dans des
montagnes d'accès très difficile s'ils
organisent les troupes nationalistes de
tchang kaï chek les troupes du komintern
lance de 1929 et 1930 4,5 campagne
d'extermination contre cette base rouge
qui se proclame m en 1931 république
soviétique chinoise
finalement les forces communistes très
inférieurs en nombre doivent décrocher
c'est la longue marche
elle durera 1 70 mille hommes rompre
l'encerclement s'en vont a pris au
hasard
traqué par les années soixante dix mille
hommes dont il restera à peine dix mille
à l'arrivée après cette retraite de 12
milles 500 km dans une nature souvent
impitoyable par exemple lors du passage
de la rivière tu as tout qui a
abondamment inspiré les illustrateurs
fibre en octobre 1935
on s'arrête et l'on plante le drapeau
rouge dans les collines du chêne si
septentrionale très loin au nord ouest
de la chine
et mao tsé toung qui a dirigé la longue
marche peut dire à ses hommes qu'ils ont
le droit d'être fiers de cette longue
marche restera gravé dans l'histoire
de nouveau une armée rouge chinois se
reconstitue de 1936 à 1945
la république populaire de iéna aura le
temps de s'organiser de 5 ans 10 et de
se fortifier
les collines de jelen sont percés de
grottes où les dirigeants communistes
entendent installer leurs maisons la mao
écrit sur la guerre l'économie
la littérature est là il écrit et il
enseigne s'efforçant de réaliser dans
l'optique nouvelles du marxisme le vieux
rêve chinois du gouvernement par la
pensée mao a compté sur l'éloignement
il a calculé que les troupes de tchang
kaï chek n'oserait pas s'aventurer si
loin de leurs bases
pourtant en 1936 chant kaï chek à
essayer encore de lancer une campagne
contre les communistes mais il a dû y
renoncer et même conclure avec une
nouvelle alliance
on verra chang au cours de réunions
d'état-major s'entretenir
cérémonieusement avec le bras droit de
marc houle très subtil et séduisant
schwahn live pourquoi cette sorte
d'union sacrée parce qu'en 1937 un fait
nouveau ces produits l'invasion
japonaise
déjà maître de la mandchourie les
soldats de l'empiré du soleil levant se
sont rués sur le reste de la chine
beaucoup mieux armés beaucoup mieux
équipés
les japonais progressent au début très
rapidement semant la mort et la terreur
les grandes villes toutes les régions
côtières seront progressivement occupé
la chine partiellement conquise le
restera jusqu'en 1945
pourtant les troupes du mikado finiront
par s'enliser en quelque sorte dans
l'immensité chinoise non sans s'être
déshonorée par d'effroyables massa
replié à chongqing shanghai chèque le
dieu guerrier a tenu jusqu'au bout quand
le japon capitule devant les alliés il
fait figure de vainqueur mais ay henan
mao a dirigé une autre résistance plus
active peut être plus incisive
les américains commencent à être curieux
de cette autre chine qu'on dit plus
juste plus efficace
pourtant ce sont les troupes de tchang
kaï chek que les américains transportent
dans leur avion équipe pour leur
permettre de surclasser les communistes
car la guerre civile reprendre
elle reprend d'abord dans les neiges de
mansouri
en trois ans les communistes
matériellement inférieur mais plus
résolue mieux accueilli aussi par la
population vont transformer l'imposante
armée du kuomintang en une lamentable
porte le fuyard 1949 les rouges force le
passage du yang tsé kiang réputée
infranchissable
pour les nationalistes c'est l'hallali
shanghai le grand port marquée par la
longue présence des européens vis depuis
longtemps dans des soubresauts de fin de
régime
un dollar américain vaut 200 mille
dollars chinois corruption et trahisons
sont partout on exécute dans la rue pour
l'exemple
bientôt il ne restera plus aux troupes
de shanghai chacun embarqué abandonnant
la chine continentale pour l'île de
formose les européens qui furent
longtemps les vrais maîtres le shanghai
s'en vont aussi
sur les talons de la vieille chine la
chine nouvelle aride
mao passé trop victorieuse en revue du
haut d'une jeep américaine récupérer sur
l'ennemi avec des tonnes et des tonnes
de matériel intact le drapeau
nationaliste tombe remplacé par un
drapeau nouveau
et du nord au sud toute la chine célèbre
ses 20 heures parti de rien partis de
leur grotte de iéna cette arme est si
pauvre début mais qui a su comme le
voulait mao être dans le peuple comme un
poisson dans l'eau
le 1er octobre 1949 mao tsé toung
proclame la république populaire de
chine à pékin
l'ancienne capitale des empereurs qui va
désormais connaître les cérémonies d'un
style nouveau
deux mois plus tard mao tsé toung est à
moscou il a 56 ans c'est son premier
voyage à l'étranger
dès son arrivée devant molotov et boules
canine ils proclament l'unité du monde
communiste
ça y est nous y fions pas nouvelle mais
un rosé bon ça nous ferions frères ou
soeurs
malgré cette déclaration d'allégeance
staline n'a jamais spécialement apprécié
les communistes chinois antilles il
devine des rivaux possibles
pourtant cette fois il se décide à
passer avec eux un traité en bonne et
due forme
il accorde à la chine une aide
financière de 300 millions de dollars ce
n'est pas énorme mais c'est mieux que
rien
surtout cette alliance va amener en
chine un flot de techniciens soviétiques
qui aideront puissamment
l'industrialisation
car la chine à l'exemple du grand frère
soviétique rêve d'acier mais la première
mesure du nouveau gouvernement a été
pour les femmes mais 1950 interdiction
de la vente des femmes et de la
polygamie
on va s'efforcer de substituer à l'image
encore récente de la chinoise au pied
bandé celle de la travailleuse de choc
et même de la femme parachutistes
et
en chine une des clés du pouvoir et à la
campagne ce qui l'avait déjà fait pour
les paysans de lénine mao va l'étendre
en 1950 à l'ensemble du pays
les paysans viennent mettre publiquement
en l'accusation leurs propriétaires
fonciers lui reprochant ses dureté son
usure les impôts payés parfois vingt ans
à la force pour mater toute résistance à
cette révolution agraire on promulgue
début 1951 le décret sur la suppression
des contre révolutionnaires qui fera des
millions de mains 47 millions d'hectares
39 millions d'outils agricoles sont
confisqués et distribué à 300 millions
de paysans plus tard à partir de 1953
ces petites propriétés individuelles
seront collectiviser
la politique chinoise et fait désormais
d'alternance
il y a les périodes du sourire comme la
fameuse période des cent fleurs que cent
fleurs s'épanouissent et que rivalise
sans école de pensée
et puis les périodes dures où les
visages se ferment ou les camps de
concentration se rouvre et où la chine
crise on les fait à l'amérique en mai
mao décrète le grand bond en avant la
vie dans les campagnes devient
monastique et militaires les villageois
se transforme en paysan soldats ne
posant la pêche que pour prendre le
fusil quelques millions d'intellectuels
des villes sont envoyés se recycler au
chant
les hommes et leurs cantines les femmes
à leur atelier la vie privée réduite au
minimum les jeunes ménages ne se
retrouvant que quelques heures par jour
et les enfants pris en charge par les
communes populaires
cela ne durera pas très longtemps
un an plus tard mao tsé toung à
l'humiliation de reconnaître l'échec du
grand bond en avant devant son allié
croûte choc
en fait entre russes et chinois il ya
longtemps que les épines grandi sous les
fleurs
en 1960
crouch up après une dernière embrassades
rappellera tous les techniciens
soviétique travaillant en chine et en
1966 les gardes rouges conspirant avec
la même fureur les révisionnistes
soviétique et ceux des dirigeants
chinois qui leur est prêté une oreille
trop favorable joignant la raillerie à
l'invectivé il baptisera rue anti
révisionnistes et voitures anti
révisionniste la rue et les voitures de
l'ambassade du rsa pékin entre temps il
y a eu la bombe atomique chinoise la
chine désormais la plus besoin de
protecteur
entre temps aussi et surtout à éclater
la révolution culturelle premier acte la
baignade dans le yang tsé kiang mao mise
en échec au comité central qui
trouvaient ses méthodes trop aventureuse
s'était retiré à shanghai loin du
pouvoir il reparaît et par cette longue
séance de natation montre qu'à 73 ans il
est toujours solide deuxième acte les
gars de rouge pour balayer les
dignitaires du parti qui lui sont
hostiles
mao fait appel aux champs et les jeunes
par milliers déferle sur les grandes
villes dans un immense défoulement que
mao et ses partisans vont canaliser en
leur faveur
c'est la guerre des affiches les gardes
rouges en écrivent des milliers pour
réclamer la destitution des ennemis de
mao des bureaucrates et en premier lieu
du président de la république nous
chaouchi
ohé
you chaouchi sera démis et disparaîtra
le spontanéisme de ces jeunes a parfois
des résultats brutaux on ne se contente
pas de fermer les antilles terre des
monuments inestimable sont endommagés ou
détruits au nom du nouveau mot d'ordre
abolissons le passé pour faire place
nette à la pensée mao tse d'eau
à
pour tous un seul m les citations du
président mao contenu dans le petit bois
en vain
j'en ai pas
l'armée va prendre le relais des civils
elle va parfois rudement à femme née
l'ordre dans le pays
il en certaines provinces étaient au
bord de l'anarchie ou 9e congrès du
parti en 1969 triomphe de mao du petit
livre et de l'armée son chef le maréchal
inkia est devenu le deuxième personnage
de la chine
or dit que la femme de mao tsé tôt elle
aussi devient un dirigeant de premier
plan
officiellement c'est l'apogée de la
révolution culturelle
en fait c'est déjà la fin de cette
aventure laventure la plus
extraordinaire peut être de l'histoire
du maoïsme
mais avant la nouvelle période de pause
qui va commencer un dernier feu
d'artifice
on va
en 1970 la mission française dirigée par
andré bettencourt renoue le contact avec
une chine qui s'ouvre un peu de nouveau
à l'étranger après la longue fermeture
de la révolution culturelle à compter de
mao tsé toung link yao est encore le
dauphin officiel
link yao est l'inventeur du petit livre
rouge qui à cette époque fais encore
partie de la vie quotidienne de 800
millions de chinois
ils doivent sans pénétrer chaque jour
soit individuellement soit
collectivement
de la révolution culturelle la chine a
gardé une allure militante et militaires
dans les universités les étudiantes et
les étudiants défilent comme des soldats
les symboles anti-américain
n'empêcheront pas nixon de visite et
bientôt la grande muraille
lorsque georges pompidou arrive en 1973
à pékin la révolution culturelle n'est
plus qu'un souvenir et link yao a
disparu démasqué comme traître il serait
mort version officielle en essayant de
fuir vers l'urss c'est chou en lai qui
symbolise brillamment la continuité de
l'état tandis que les pousses de mao tsé
toung règne sur la vie culturelle
ancienne actrice
la femme du président a supprimé tout le
répertoire traditionnel de l'opéra de
pékin et la fait remplacer par six
opéras modèle de style occidental et
d'inspiration révolutionnaire
sur toutes les scènes de chine les rois
les dieux et les démons de l'ancien
opéra ont disparu pour faire place aux
paysans et aux ouvriers
e
ans
au delà
à
non
chine
mobilisez vous l'on chante
l'internationale dans les salles de
théâtre et où mao tsé toung est visible
jusque dans la cabine du grutier
surveillants de haut le complexe
sidérurgique de pékin chine
enfin admise par le monde enfin présente
aux nations unies mais qui garde quelque
chose de son repliement sur elle-même
chine où les dernières portes de pékin
les derniers cyclo-pousse vivent à leur
demande
mao présent partout avec son image
multiplier à l'infini
oui
nous sommes des sceaux d'un paysan nous
devons gagner la bataille telle
production
cette année la moisson de blé est
strictement la production a augmenté
d'environ 30% pour le riz nous avons de
l'espoir
nous devions bien surveiller la
plantation afin que la production soit
supérieure à celle de l'année dernière
il y a de la sécheresse mais en
appliquant la pensée de montres dont
nous pouvons vaincre les sifi coca
à
chez nous à partir du moment où on
accepte la pensée de mort de don chacun
peut s'exprimer librement
nous encourageons la pensée de mort de
don aura stimulé les éléments positifs
des masses chinoises
paysans de mao soldats de mao chine de
mao que sera demain la chine après mao
ouais
à
et
je vous rappelle encore une fois que
tout de suite après ce journal jean
marie cavada animera un débat qui sera
consacré à la mort du président mao tsé
toung il sera entouré de nombreuses
personnalités spécialiste des problèmes
de la chine
le débat sera précédée d'un film inédit
vous pourrez comme pour les dossiers de
l'écran participer à ce débat en
appelant svp et cela à partir de 21h
donc vous pouvez appeler à partir de 21h
après mao que se passera-t-il en chine
c'est bien là la question qui se pose
déjà car la chine n'est pas un pays
comme les autres avec 800 millions
d'habitants pratiquement un quart de la
population du globe son importance pour
l'avenir du monde est démesuré
paradoxalement pourrait-on dire dans ce
pays collectiviste mao tsé toung était
un mythe
et même si peu à peu il s'était retiré
du gouvernement effectif
il restait le chef spirituel à travers
ces fameuses pensée regroupés dans le
petit livre rouge
cela dit dans l'avenir immédiat des
structures de gouvernement sont en place
en chine mais il reste que la
disparition d'un homme qui s'était
pratiquement identifié à son peuple
n'ira pas à long terme sans poser de
problème n'est pas morte ce taux était
de par sa longévité
sa longévité politique bien sûr de part
son le génie multiples et de par sa
stature ce qu'un homme tout de même des
mesures et pendant ce temps tous les
plans cet homme régnait pratiquement sur
la chine depuis 30 ans comme staline
lénine avait pu le faire et il est
irremplaçable ce titre et cela nous
condamnent par conséquent presque au
système de la collégialité
malheureusement dans la chine
d'aujourd'hui
cette collégialité se présente sous des
auspices assez défavorable car la
succession de man n'est pas réglé les
factions qui était qui rivalisaient
jusqu'à demain jusqu'à l'arrêt pendant
la révolution culturelle continue à
exister même le départ de tokyo ping n'a
été suivie d'aucune d'élimination espace
web dans les instances suprêmes soi ou à
la tête des provinces ce sont toujours
les mêmes responsables qui sont là et
par conséquent on se trouve
devant une situation qui appelle le
compromis comme elle a déjà appelé le
compromis au moment de la nomination
trois coffres
est ce que justement le premier ministre
a les épaules assez solides
bien sûr la question que tout le monde
se pose parce que je crois qu'au fond il
est tout à fait un nouveau venu
c'est un homme de l'appareil
traditionnel c'est un cadre provinciale
il a l'expérience des réalités il ne
semble pas être idéologue ses traits de
caractère sont tout de même encore assez
indéterminée le passe pour un homme
énergique pour un homme très intelligent
ça ne suffit pas et il est déjà été
contestée je crois vous savez tous les
dirigeants ont été contestés n'est ce
pas juste quatre là et je crois que seul
mot ce tour lui même il a échappé alors
le fait qu'un dirigeant était contesté
un moment ou un autre de la révolution
culturelle ou après ne signifie pas ce
disgrâce politique
cette mort ne risque-t-elle pas de
remettre en cause la stabilité politique
et l'unité de la chine
l'unité de la chine je le crois pas
parce que cette unité tout de même a
fait de grands progrès sous le régime
actuel et je pense que tous les
dirigeants sont conscients
la stabilité politique c'est possible je
veux dire que des équipes peuvent se
succéder au pouvoir est en fait depuis
deux ou trois ans c'est ce à quoi on
assiste tantôt c'est une tendance
modérée tantôt c'est une tendance
beaucoup plus radicale n'est ce pas
comme celle qui a amené et puis renvoyé
est un club ping alors on risque d'avoir
une situation un peu changeantes comme
celle là